I I've been open about this I mean I saw
an object when I was young as a as a
paper boy uh and it went right over my
head it was you know it was un uh
unmistakable uh you know that it was not
supposed to be there so that when the
whole subject of what UFOs or whatnot
might be I could look back on that and
say well you know insofar as what
everybody else is claiming this to be
that was a UFO
um but you know as I explained this
through to um Avi at one point uh it's
an anecdote and so it is not sufficient
for me to use that as proof of anything
except to myself
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
when I talk about uh these these
subjects with Tom Delong he mentioned a
problem that he has but he's not a
scientist so he could get away with it
and that was that he claimed to have
alien technology an artifact from a
downed craft and he claims that it's 100
genuine we have material from a
purported crash in the late 40s we don't
really have a chain of title all the way
back then we do for like 20 years or
something we know there's a lot of
anomalies about the way it's engineered
we have some theories of what it can do
there's been a lot of studies on it the
government's very interested in this
piece but if that piece ended up being
real then it's like well what else was
it a part of and who was piloting this
thing was it a drone was it not however
the means by which he acquired it cannot
be either divulged or reproduced in
other words there's a chain of custody
problem that Avi and I don't suffer from
right if Avi and I look at a uh at a
muon uh their muons are like Commodities
they're fungible one meal you've seen
one mealon you've seen them all they're
they're entertain changeable but but
alien craft aren't and so therefore it's
very important the provenance so to
speak and I and I guess I'm wondering
you know from your excursions what do
you make of of the claims of say autonom
or
Jacques Valley who I know you've worked
with well if he's if he's talking about
the uh the so-called
um magnesium bismuth metamaterial
um you know I I have pieces of that uh
and I don't think that there is
sufficient evidence at this point to
claim that is clearly uh you know from
an extraterrestrial vehicle
um that said I don't think that's
sufficient analysis has been done on it
it does have slightly altered magnesium
ratios I've I've looked at that myself
but they're not so far off that they
that they can't be um construed as some
other sort of reason for you know in the
in the making of it so unless he's
talking about something else I I don't I
don't know and nor have I seen it uh the
the evidence and so it's I I put it into
the into the anecdote category and I
like Tom I mean I'm I I'm you know he's
a friend uh but I I haven't seen
anything else now I have been given
pieces of material that do have chains
of evidence this is the so-called
ubatuba event where we did do a very
detailed uh analysis using secondary
iron Mass Spec of the isotope ratios of
two pieces one was and we did it in the
same instrument at the same time under
the same vacuum conditions uh one piece
was perfectly conventional
magnesium ratios the other were way off
I mean so far off as to be the only
thing that I could imagine is it was
manufacture now that doesn't prove it's
a UAP it doesn't prove it was alien it
just says to me somebody back in the 70s
spent a lot of money to change the
isotope ratios and then blew it up over
a beach in Brazil and so the only
question it raises to me is who would do
that and why would they do it right I
mean because we we don't use Isotopes or
anything other than either medical
reasons or blowing stuff up just a quick
pause to ask you for a small favor while
my thumb is occupied with old Albert on
it yours is presumably freed up to leave
a thumbs up on this video really helps
me a lot with a good old-fashioned
YouTube algorithm thanks a lot now back
to the video I think scientists are like
children I mean we don't play well with
others we're very jealous we like
attention and we and we don't like to
share our toys right so I want to ask
Gary when uh when we see things like
this and Avi please you too and I just
want to remind everybody we're talking
about Navi lobe Gary Nolan uh some of
the most eminent uh scientists who
happen to have turned at Great personal
risk and I want to say this with respect
um I don't have the courage that you
guys do I kind of do this because I
believe that we as scientists have a
moral obligation to share the data to
share the discoveries in a way that our
tax paying public who pay our freaking
salaries I don't care you guys are at
private institutions I'm at a public
institution but you guys are supported
by the public at a very deep level as
well I just want to put that out there I
feel it's my moral obligation to share
it but I don't have the courage to go
out on a limb to go on Tucker Carlson
like like Gary to go on the various
Outlets that that you've gone on as well
Avi because I I I'm worried I'm worried
about the the obviously there's there's
career risk Etc but there's also kind of
a intellectual capture that occurs when
when you believe something to be true
that no one else maybe agrees with you
or very few of your colleagues agree
with you it's a very lonely place and
I'm just saying in all honesty not many
scientists have that courage not many uh
people have that courage is the rarest
of all human emotions in my opinion so I
just want to express that but I do want
to say along the lines of data I've
heard people say and when Avi was on
with Eric Weinstein we heard things like
the data is ours it belongs to the
public I don't know if I necessarily
disagree that the data belongs to the
public but don't we have an obligation a
scientist Gary to interpret the data are
very complex someone who's watching this
channel may be a layperson very bright
brilliant I mean the smartest audience
in the universe watches this channel but
do they have of the tools to assess at
the level that you do because of your
access because of the privilege that you
have to be a scientist can an average
layperson really understand what it is
that maybe you might be claiming or is
it your job to explain it in a way that
they could
belong I mean again and this is kind of
a literally a riff on what
um or what Avi just said I don't think
of frankly what we're doing as
courageous I'm just doing what I thought
science was teaching me to do right and
that's really what Avi was saying is
that you know that that if if science is
about following rules that somebody else
wrote on stone tablets then science is
done right and so uh I've spent my whole
career doing things that people told me
shouldn't or couldn't be done like when
I was doing starting companies back in
the early 90s or mid 90s I was told
you're gonna you know destroy your
career you shouldn't do it now everybody
does it right and people people who used
to come to me and tell them I'm ruining
my career come and ask me how to start a
company uh so that's that's fine so I
don't consider it I don't consider it
courageous I'm just doing what I think
we're supposed to be doing
foreign
[Music]